What has been the one thing that came up that was perhaps the most
controversial?
Like I know my friend Sam Harris was trying to get you guys to ban Donald Trump.
He was saying if the fall,
your terms of service,
I just did a podcast with him.
Actually you should come out today or tomorrow.
He's uh,
he's a,
he's a fascinating guy.
Sam Harris.
I love him to death.
But what he was trying to do was like saying,
hey,
he's threatening nuclear war.
Like he's saying,
Hey Korea,
my bombs are bigger than your bombs.
Like what else does the guy have to do to get your,
to remove them from the platform?
When you guys saw that,
what,
what was your reaction to that?
Was there an internal discussion about actually banning the president of United
States?
Well,
so,
so two things there.
One,
it was a context that presidents of this country have you similar language in
different mediums.
They use it on radio,
they use it on television.
It's not just through Twitter.
And even if you were looked at,
you were to look at the presidency of Obama.
It wasn't exactly the same tone in this exact same language,
but there were threats around the same country.
And we have to take that context into consideration.
So the second thing is that we need them.
The most controversial aspect of our rules and uh,
our terms of service has probably this clause around public interest in
newsworthiness where,
um,
powerful figures are public figures might be in violation of our terms of
service,
but the tweet itself is of public interest.
Yes,
there should be a conversation around it and that is probably the thing that
people disagree with the most.
Um,
and where we have a lot of internal debate,
but we also have some pretty hard lines.
If we had a global leader,
including the president of United States,
make a violent threat against a private individual,
we would take action.
We,
we always have to balance that with like,
is this a,
is this something that the public has interest in in,
I believe generally the answer is yes.
It's not going to be in every case.
But generally the answer's yes.
Because we should see how our leaders think and how they act in essentially,
I don't forms voting that informs the conversation then forms whether we think
they're going to,
they're doing the right job or we think that,
you know,
they should be,
uh,
they should be voted out.
Well,
it's very important to see how someone uses that platform and when someone uses
it the way he uses it and then becomes president and continues to use it that
way,
that's when people like what he's been consistent and I think he,
I think he joined
2009,
2012 and yeah.
You look at all of his tweets all the way back then and pretty consistent too.
Yeah.
He likes to insult people on Twitter.
It's for him.
It's just,
I never thought he would keep doing it.
I thought once he became president,
maybe just lock it down and tried to do a good job for the country and then,
you know,
after four years or eight years,
just go back to his old self,
fuck you fuck the world.
Fuck this.
Yeah.
But no,
he's,
he's just cute.
It's just in one way it's hilarious.
See,
as a comedian,
I think it's awesome because it's just,
it's so hilariously stupid.
It's so preposterous.
That even has the time to talk about Jeff Bezos is a fair and the fact that he
got caught with the national enquirer getting text messages and calls him Jeff
Bozo like,
don't you have shit to do man.
As,
but as a comedian,
I,
I am a gigantic fan of folly,
almost a against my better judgment.
I like watching it's,
I,
I want,
I like watching disasters.
I like watching chaos.
When I see nonsense like that and like,
oh Jesus,
like I,
I'm drawn like a motto flame.
But on the other part of me is like,
man,
this sets a very bizarre tone for the entire country because one of the things
about Obama,
like Obama or hate Obama seems very measured,
very articulate,
obviously very well educated.
And I think that that aspect of his presidency was very good for all of us
because he represented something that was of a very high standard in terms of
his ability to communicate his access to words,
the way the way measured his words and held himself.
I think that that's good for us.
Like,
yeah.
Well it's,
It's like,
look at that guy.
He's talked better than me.
That's why he's the president.
But you know,
you ladies see Trump,
he like,
he's doesn't talk better than me.
He does.
He doesn't use Twitter better.
He's not,
he's just this fucking mad men.
But isn't it important to understand that and to see it exactly.
To,
hopefully that informs opinions and actions 100% that's my point.
That's my point is like that this is this weird gray area where I think overall,
I definitely support your decision to not,
not banned him for violating your terms of service.
Like we need to know.
Yeah.